patriots insider for nbc sports boston
tom
e curran joining us on the program how
is morale in new england tom
skye flipping hi dan i mean through the
flipping roofs out here
because because nobody anticipated this
kind of start i mean
i i was on the cynical side i said eight
and eight but if you really put
uh the pressure on me i would have told
you seven and nine
and instead what we're watching is and
this is the most
interesting thing is cam newton making
players better especially at the wide
receiver position
than we thought that they were he threw
32 times to wideouts the other day
nikhil harry career highs and targets
and catches edelman career high in yards
and damian bird
a career high in uh in targets
okay but so tom kept saying he didn't
have weapons there
um cam is thrown to the same weapons
that tom had
so what's the difference well
i mean honestly i think it's 11 on 11
football as opposed to 10 on 11.
that threat to run that he brings to the
table means the defense has to commit an
extra guy
how scary he was in the opener against
miami
with the 75 yards really got into the
heads of
the defense and ken norton jr and how
they were going to try and deal with cam
and that opened stuff up which we saw
in the second half for guys down the
field and newton hit the throws
and guys made plays for him so we'll see
how
how long it proceeds that way but he's
now done one of each
gone off on the ground and gone off
through the air
and you know that versatility is awesome
and it keeps the defense
you know uh off guard there a little bit
and belichick has to love that it gives
him
you know a lot more toys or the
possibilities to play with but
that was my question about the
sustainability of this i don't know what
is the offense going to change
each week as belichick has done before
there are times when they were a running
team
and then all of a sudden they become a
passing team and then
back to a running game so i i don't know
what is the game plan i think that's the
intention and that's why they
like seattle are a program they do the
stuff
that they do over such a long course of
time long period of time
and are able to stay the course and
switch now seattle doesn't switch as
much as the patriots do but that's the
patriots dna whatever you're going to
bring into our
game we're going to try and exploit or
stay away from depending upon how it
works for us so
you know with mcdaniels and that's the
interesting thing is
they spend the first quarter oftentimes
to quarter and a half
just probing and trying to figure out
had they not been staked to that seven
nothing lead the other night i wonder
how it would have looked but
you know each week will be an
interesting test as the leagues
continues to to gain info on them
explain this belichick over the top with
compliments with cam
calculated yeah i think so i think he
wants to make sure that cam feels
extremely welcome
that they want him here that he wasn't a
guy that they just picked as a last
resort because they didn't feel like
jared stidham could get things done
that he's exceeded what they thought he
would do and
i think he also probably wants to tamp
down expectations look everybody up here
everybody who wasn't in carolina
had an image of cam as maybe a little
bit self-absorbed and narcissistic
and i don't know selfish is the right
word but
i think the main impetus for mcdaniels
or his teammates
or belichick have been to say look he
doesn't care about anything
except working hard bringing energy and
winning football games
and i think that helps because you know
we're learning that as opposed to
what we got as the cam newton brand
which was
you know a dynamic player who also had
bizarre outfits that
you know oftentimes we would register
impressions on
so i think bill's trying to push back
against what the perception is
what about a long-term contract for kim
how
how much does he have to produce how
many games is
are they going to stay with the
million-dollar bargain here what would
you do
if you were cam i mean he's he had a 100
million dollar contract he just came off
of
but if you're 32 and the whole week just
passed on you and the patriots gave you
a million dollar contract would you
think you were indebted
to the patriots i wonder about that what
would you
i mean honestly or do you want to just
market your services
well if i'm cam i'm i well i think
everybody wanted
it was a look-see that they weren't sure
because they couldn't work him out they
didn't know how healthy he was
and did i think there would be other
teams that would show interest
absolutely
um i was surprised when ron rivera did
not bring him to washington
but you know they wanted to give haskins
a chance and i understand it
but i if i'm cam i just bet on myself
but i just don't know the market for a
quarterback
who plays that way who's going to be 33
30 32 33 years of age
am i giving you a three-year deal for 80
million dollars
like i mean i don't know you got four
years of since 2016
17 18 and 19 you have four years of
evidence that show
well it can be a little bit tender
in terms of being injured there is
shoulder issues there have been leg
issues
do we want to bet on this guy can we
craft an offense around him if we're
someplace else
and that to me is it's that's why these
two games while so
impressive they don't really necessarily
make anybody say well crap we have to
make sure that we're in line to
to get this guy to replace whoever is at
our quarterback position and it's
isn't it interesting dan how many teams
actually have
answers or plausible answers at the
quarterback position in the nfl right
now
well also where's jared stidham like you
know he's
inactive i know but so that was supposed
to be a competition and i think we all
said there is no competition here but
let's say cam's a one in donor in new
england
then are they still looking for a
quarterback or do they have their
quarterback instead
i don't think that they they saw nothing
from jared stidham in this offseason
that would make them nod in approval and
say we're all set
yeah i mean he had an opportunity to
compete he got hurt
and then when he came off being injured
just you know kind of a slight injury he
didn't really perform
very well in training camp no preseason
game so he was he was
you know sol but if i were the patriots
i would start to
show up for the engagement ring right
now to try and present it to cam at some
point
around thanksgiving just at least start
pricing the things out
do patriot fans want brady to succeed do
you think
seemingly no the vocal ones on social
media the ones who call into
um the radio shows the ones that that
i'm encountering are taking a
specific glee first in the performance
the first week and then in diminishing
what brady did last week and i don't get
it i mean to a degree i do
because it was framed as if brady
abandoned the patriots when the
actuality is that they
they're all set with tom a couple years
ago but i think there's a glee that's
being derived from
hey look at our new friend and with
brady
yeah well i love the outfit but who
would wear those shoes i mean
i mean it's just it's amazing to me
and belichick's okay with these uh
post-game outfits that cam wears
yeah i mean i don't think it even
registers now here's one thing dan and
i'm sure we're close to the brit but
so after the game the other night
they're in freaking
seattle it took cam probably an hour to
pop up for his post game press
video conference with us so i'm guessing
they want to get to the airport
they have buses they got one plane maybe
two i don't know probably two because of
the cobit but
he's taking an hour to get his hat
straightened and everything attired and
they're sitting in seattle and it's
one o'clock eastern and i
i can't i don't know i don't know how
that goes over
do you believe that belichick has not
been watching the buccaneers
yes i do i think that he uh you don't
think he's
curious i don't wow
i don't i really don't i mean i i don't
i mean i think he knows what's going on
but i don't think he's digesting and
registering
opinions i really don't like everybody
else might be i was also curious about
gronk like i could see a patriot fans
had a problem with gronk but not brady
and gronk has been sort of m.i.a there
what uh and maybe you only need him for
a couple of games in the postseason and
that's really
they got tight ends but what do you make
of uh gronk's performance
i think he's a little bit scared right
now
and i don't blame him the punishment
that he took for the first
nine years of his career through 2018
was such that it left him kind of a
mental mess and he talked about it prior
to the super bowl three days before with
me and he talked about it after the
super bowl so now he's back in the pool
and he knows his body is going to get
whacked and he's going to throw himself
and he's already
dan made the decision to say i want out
i don't want to do this anymore
and now in theory it was okay let's get
back into it maybe it'll be fun down
there with tom and now he's on the field
and he's looking at him like
this kind of sucks these guys are trying
to kill me again
i thought i was out now i'm back in
yeah it's uh you see that yeah i do i do
i and i don't think he can quit on tom
this time
it just feels like he's gonna he's gonna
stay and you know
but i i'm gonna grind it out i don't
think it's physical
i hate to say i think that's probably
mental it's been a mental challenge for
him
you know there was a game on a sunday
night in 2015 in denver
in the snow when the patriots were 10-0
and grunk got hit in the knee
by someone i can't remember who it was
and he rolled around on the ground like
he was gonna have to have an amputation
turned out it was a bruise but and
that's not to make
light of the punishment he took but i
think it's always in his mind
that there's a devastating hit that's
about to ruin him and he's had so many
surgeries and gone through so much pain
i don't blame him for being having so
much trepidation about it
oh so after two games bills of the
patriots win the division
duh bills bills i don't know i'm i'm
still
jury's still out for me with cameron
newton okay
it's great to talk to you that was a
nice visit yeah it was it was pleasant
for a change
yeah thanks for being nice yeah maybe
maybe bring some drama next time say hi
to the fellas
i will that's tom e curran he's the uh
nbc sports boston insider he's a patriot
insider